WE'RE BACK WITH FOX NEWS ALERT
OUT OF STOCKTON, CALIFORNIA
WHERE A SERIAL KILLER IS ON THE
LOOSE THIS IS MAN LAW
ENFORCEMENT THINK COULD BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR AT LEAST FIVE
DEATHS.
AND STOCKTON OVER THE LAST FEW
MONTHS, THE VICTIMS WERE
AMBUSHED, IN THE DARK AND SHOT
SINGLY WITHOUT ANY EXPLANATION.
THE SUSPECT HAS ALSO BEEN LINKED
TO KILLING IN OAKLAND HUNDREDS
OF TIPS HAVE BEEN POURING IN,
AND 125,000 DOLLAR REWARD IS
BEING OFFERED.
JOINING ME NOW STORK STOCKTON
PRAYING YOU GUYS WHAT CAN YOU
TELL ME ABOUT THIS SERIAL
KILLER?
>> YEAH THANK YOU LAWRENCE.
WELL WE ESTABLISHED A TASK FORCE
MADE UP OF FEDERAL, STATE AND
LOCAL PARTNERS TO FIND THIS
INDIVIDUAL THESE INDIVIDUALS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THESE MURDERS
AND TO BRING THEM TO JUSTICE.
AS THE PUBLIC COULD SEE WE
RELEASED VIDEO OF LAST WEEK THAT
PROVIDES SOME DESCRIPTION OF THE
INDIVIDUAL.
SOME OF HIS OR HER SOME OF THEIR
BEHAVIOR THEIR MANNERISM
APPROXIMATE HEIGHT 5 TEN TO 6
FEET TALL, AS YOU STATED
EARLIER, THIS INDIVIDUAL THESE
MURDERS HAVE HAPPENED LATE IN
THE EVENING.
EARLY IN THE MORNING, SO WE'RE
ENCOURAGING THE PUBLIC JUST TO
BE ON HEIGHT AND ALERT LISTEN
WE'RE DOING EVERYTHING THAT WE
CAN WITHIN OUR POWER AND
UTILIZING EVERY RESOURCE THAT WE
HAVE AT OUR DISPOSE TOLL BRING
THIS PERSON TO JUSTICE THERE'S
NOT A WORD THAT I CAN SAY THAT
CAN RETURN THOSE LOST LOVED ONES
BUT LEAST THAT WE CAN DO AS A
COMMUNITY AS A CITY IS WE CAN DO
EVERYTHING TWOAK BRING THIS
INDIVIDUAL TO JUSTICE AND TO
PROVIDE SOME SORT OF RESOLUTION
FOR THE FAMILIES IN THE
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED.
SMG MOST DEFINITE MAYOR TOAPGHT
MAKE SURE SPBL SAFE FORGIVE ME
FOR THIS QUESTION IS THERE A
POTENTIAL MOTIVE A POTENTIAL --
VICTIM THAT HE GOES AFTER OF
BECAUSE WE WANT PEOPLE TO BE ON
ALERT OR IS HE JUST DOING IT TO
ANYONE?
>> THIS PERSON OR --
THIS PERSON OR THESE PERSONS ARE
ON A MISSION TO KILL.
THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE DOING.
80% OF THE HOMICIDES IN STOCKTON
ARE HISPANIC.
WE HAVE ONE SIXTH INDIVIDUAL IN
STOCKTON VICTIM WHO WAS A
SURVIVER FROM BACK IN APRIL OF
2021.
SO LISTEN, THERE'S NO MOTIVE
THAT IS ESTABLISHED AT THIS
POINT BUT WE'RE JUST TELLING
PUBLIC, IF YOU HAVE ANY
INFORMATION THAT CAN LEAD TO THE
ARREST OF THIS INDIVIDUAL OF
THESE INDIVIDUALS RESPONSIBLE,
NOW IS THE TIME TO SPEAK UP.
THERE'S $125,000 REWARD THIS
COMMUNITY HAS COME TOGETHER
PUBLIC NONPROFIT PARTNERSHIPS
HAVE COME TOGETHER TO MAKE THIS
AWARD WHAT IT IS THAT REWARD
TODAY AND I EXPECT THAT WILL GO
UP BECAUSE ONE THING THAT THE
RESIDENTS OF STOCKTON DO WHEN WE
EXPERIENCE A TIME AND MOMENT OF
CRISIS, WE COME TOGETHER.
AND WE GO STRONGER AND WE WILL
GET TO THE BOTTOM OF THIS.
LAWRENCE: WE HAVE THE TIP LINE
UP ON THE BOTTOM OF THE SCREEN.
IF YOU HAVE ANY INFORMATION THAT
CAN LEAD TO THE CAPTURE OF THIS
KILLER --
OR THESE KILLERS AS THE MAYOR
SAID PLEASE REACH OUT.
MAYOR, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
COMING ON AND WE HOPE THAT WE
CAN CHASM THIS GUY